I've been talking with some of my
girlfriends and what I'm noticing is
more and more they're just turning away
from even getting into relationships
they're not interested in dating some of
them are actually not even interested in
men anymore so they're kind of going the
other way the problem that a lot of
women have today these women that are
like they have to be boss girls in their
career to do what they're doing and they
don't want to deal with men is that
they're not able or willing to enter a
man's frame and comply women have been
told to go and Chase the degree they
don't need no man go and work and then
they hear all these songs about being a
hashtag boss girl and bad [ __ ] and all
that kind of stuff they think that
they're the bomb but do they know how to
cook do they know how to like please a
guy do they know how to be pleasant well
I want to date the good looking guy but
you know he's going to cheat on me oh
well you know a guy with options might
happen to have a couple of plates
spinning right now too and then are you
guys okay with the women having options
as well absolutely not guys that are
high value that are top shelf that are
willing to be monogamous you better
treat him like a God because guys like
that are rare